some of you may have seen me attempt to
play Kong's Skull Island is that what
it's called Skull Island rise of Kong
which is probably the worst game to come
out all year I did not get very far
through it it was right up there with
gollem but what I'm about to show you is
so much worse than I ever would have
expected this is an actual cut scene
from Skull Island rise of Kong huge
shout out to me him as Prime on Reddit
for sharing this gift um because
otherwise I you know I knew it was bad
but look at
this this game came out it was just like
a still jpeg popped over the top of the
enemy that didn't even really look like
it this is a this is a real cut scene
that came in that little pop in it's
even worse than I expected apparently
they only had a year to make this game
which is why it looks the way it does
and runs the way it does I'm just so
surprised they released it at all